[Music]
foreign
so in this lecture what I'm going to do
is briefly give you a feeling for how to
compute the error of these these forward
and backward Euler schemes I'm just
going to paint like kind of the high
level sketch of this and you can dig in
deeper if you want to to look at this
for for other systems but essentially
what we're going to do is look at what
is the error of forward Euler so the
error
of the forward Euler scheme
specifically as a function of delta T as
a function
of delta T because we know that if we
make delta T smaller our error should go
down but how much faster does that error
go down
scalar differential equation some x dot
equals you know f of x or X is a scalar
but everything I'm going to tell you
generalizes to this full system of
differential equations it's just easier
for me to write down for a scalar so
again
um forward Oiler I'm just gonna we've
already written it down here but forward
Euler essentially says that you know X
at time
K plus 1 equals exit time K plus a
little delta T times F at x k
and this x at K plus 1 is approximating
X at my next time step so um X at K plus
1 is approximating
X at time k
exit time k
plus a little delta T and so what we're
going to do is we're actually going to
this is like the exact trajectory if I
had a perfect integrator exit time uh
you know TK plus delta T this is the the
True Value that I'm trying to
approximate and this forward Euler
scheme is just an approximation of this
true value
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take this expression and Taylor expand
it out and then see if we can figure out
what the error is based on this Taylor
expansion okay good
uh and so let's just do that let's
tailor expand this uh true trajectory so
we're going to tailor expand
and we're Taylor expanding the kind of
true
um next time step the true X of T K plus
delta T and that is uh X at TK plus
delta T we're going to Taylor expand in
increments of delta T and powers of
delta T about a base Point TK which is
where our trajectory is where we start
at at TK so we're just trying to compute
the error of this one time step from XK
to x k plus 1. so our base time is time
now time K and this equals x at time k
X at TK
plus the derivative of x with respect to
time plus uh you know d x d t at time t
k times delta T
plus the second derivative D squared x
DT squared at T K Delta t squared over 2
factorial plus dot dot dot okay same
stuff we've always done with the Taylor
series
um
good
this is the true trajectory we're trying
to approximate this is our actual
approximation
and so you'll notice that this
approximation here actually looks a lot
like the first two terms in the Taylor
series of the true function maybe I
should have written this you know like a
like a pink bracket around it this is
the true expression here is is all the
stuff in pink this is our approximation
up here and you'll notice that our
approximation our forward Euler
approximation looks like the first two
terms so this is
um you know x k
and this is DX DT DX DT is just f of x
and at time K that's f of x k this is f
of x k
times a delta T
so this is exactly our forward Euler is
exactly the first two terms of our
Taylor series for the actual exact
trajectory and everything else out here
to the right that's error so this is the
error
in our approximation so all of this
stuff all of these terms out here are
terms that are not being approximated by
our forward Euler and so our forward
Euler has all of this error in its
approximation it's not capturing this
you know the higher order terms here
and so that gives us a pretty good idea
right now that this scheme is second
order accurate in delta T so all of my
error scales as Delta t squared okay so
I could say that the error of my forward
Euler my error
is order Delta t squared in
um
in delta T it's order order Delta t
squared but this is for a single time
step okay so for every single little
time step my error is Delta t squared so
we sometimes call this locally this is
kind of the local or locally our error
is Delta t squared this means every time
step
but globally so if I have some
trajectory I'm trying to predict and my
trajectory you know is going let's say
from Time Zero
to time Big T whatever Big T is you
would think okay I can make my error
smaller by cutting delta T by a factor
of 10 or whatever like if I make if I
make delta T 10 times smaller my local
error gets 100 times better so that's
really good so maybe I'll chop this up
into 10 times smaller Delta T's
but then I'll have 10 times more Delta
T's and so that means that my Global
error my kind of global
or over the entire trajectory over
entire
trajectory
my Global error over the entire
trajectory because if I cut my delta T
by a factor of 10 my error does get
Delta t squared better but I also have 1
over delta T more time steps and so my
Global error is order
delta T and that's a general property
you're going to find in these
integrators if I have a scheme that is
locally ordered delta T cubed it's going
to be globally Delta t squared because I
have you know 1 over delta T more time
steps if I change the time step to make
my error smaller
so uh so the local error per time step
is Delta t squared very easy to derive
from a Taylor series it's Delta t
squared
is I'm taking 1 over delta T more time
steps my Global error is Delta t squared
times 1 over delta T which is order
delta T okay so not very good right like
this is just like my forward difference
and and backward difference derivatives
my forward Euler and backward Oiler are
going to have this Global Order delta T
error over the whole trajectory it's
going to accumulate into this large
order delta T error I didn't derive what
it is for backward Euler but actually
that's a great homework exercise for you
is do exactly what I did here for
forward Euler but convince yourself of
this for backward Oiler and you'll be
able to figure out
um I guess what you would do is you
would um
well you would use the Expression I I
wrote down for the the finite difference
derivative that you used to derive
backward Euler and then you would use a
Taylor series
um and find the error terms it's going
to be exactly the same as the upshot
okay
um good what else do I want to tell you
um
yeah we're going to cook up some schemes
that are much higher accuracy so the uh
rangakatta so we're gonna we're gonna
cook up these uh ranga Cutta schemes
runga
cutter
and the rangakata schemes we're going to
cook up a second order and a fourth
order so ranga cut a two and we're going
to cut a four that means what what that
means is it's going to be globally
second order accurate and globally
fourth order accurate so actually in
every delta T my runga cutter 2 is going
to be delta T cubed accurate and at
every delta T my run could cut a four is
going to be fifth order accurate but
that means globally over the whole
trajectory it's going to be second and
fourth order accurate and that's what I
remember
good uh what else do I want to tell you
what else do I want to tell you
going from local accuracy of every time
step technically
all you can say is what is the accuracy
across one time step
of this integrator you can only say what
is the error from XK to XK plus one and
so this local error is the only thing
you can really quantify with the Taylor
series because
for chaotic systems if f of x is a
chaotic dynamical system then that means
that the Dynamics themselves if I have
you know if there is some little Delta
error between the true trajectory and my
approximate trajectory if there's this
little Delta t squared error
in a chaotic system that little tiny
error
will actually amplify exponentially in
forward time even if I used a perfect
integrator afterwards so let me say this
again in a chaotic system if I have some
X and I add a little Epsilon to it
even if I have a perfect integrator with
no error at all I integrate a chaotic
system with no error in my integrator
but I take X and I take X plus a teeny
tiny Epsilon and I integrate those two
forward in time chaotic systems tend to
have these trajectories diverge
exponentially forward in time
which means that each of these teeny
little integration errors that I'm
accruing at every time step each of
these little integration errors is
taking me order Delta t squared off of
the true trajectory and those are
amplifying exponentially because of the
chaotic Dynamics so there again are two
sources of error here there is the error
per time step because of the Taylor
series because of my delta T and then
those errors get magnified in future
time if I have chaotic Dynamics
now for simple systems like a pendulum
which is just a deterministic Clockwork
system or for a spring Mass damper for
deterministic systems that doesn't
happen and This Global error
approximation will be valid but for
chaotic systems these little local
perturbations and and Imperfections are
going to amplify massively and become a
big problem so those are really subtle
things you have to keep track of and
that's actually a good motivation for
using these higher order rangakata
schemes because we want to keep this
Epsilon as small as possible when we're
simulating chaotic systems I'll talk a
lot more about that later so you know
that's just a teaser again for for
understanding chaotic systems but for
the simple deterministic systems that we
often care about like pendula or spring
Mass dampers then
this idea of you know taking our local
error per time step and just compounding
that multiplying that by the number of
time steps is a pretty good
approximation of our Global uh our
Global trajectory error here
okay good um so homework exercise for
you do this exact same thing but for
backward Oiler and convince yourself it
scales the same way in the in the next
lecture I'm going to look at the
stability of these integrators based on
the eigenvalues and then after that
we're going to derive the second and
fourth order runga Cutta schemes which
are much more accurate and uh and have
better Better Properties in general all
right thank you
[Music]